learning tonight senate judiciary
committee members senator mike lee tom
tillis north carolina did test positive
for the
coronavirus some democrats are actually
trying to use that news for political
gain as
yet the latest excuse to delay amy coney
barrett's confirmation process which is
supposed to start in oh
10 days schumer tonight tweeting out
quote it's irresponsible and dangerous
to move forward with a hearing
now senator mcconnell announced earlier
that amy coney barrett's confirmation
process
will move quote full steam ahead joining
us now with more
former white house press secretary fox
news contributor ari fleisher
fox news contributor jason chavets ari
start with you tonight you're
okay they politicize everything they've
not they've not wanted the president to
do what 29 presidents have done
in election years when there's a vacancy
on the supreme court i get it
the hearings aren't supposed to stop or
start for 10 days they don't need a
quorum they can't stop it mitch
mcconnell
senator graham are not going to stop it
you just have to ask yourself what's
different why now
because sean when since kova began 18
members of congress have come down with
covid
when these other members of congress
came down with kova did that stop the
democrats
did they ground congress to a halt did
they stop legislating did they stop
attacking donald trump no should they
stop over the weekend the negotiations
on the fourth stimulus package
of course they shouldn't they should
continue we have a constitution and
constitutional obligations
and they should be upheld and that
includes the naming of a supreme court
justice
especially there's no reason not to
proceed you know i i said this at the
time
uh jason i said you know if at the
height of this
uh the medical manufacturers of
of gowns and gloves and ppe and
ventilators
they didn't work new york and other
states were done
if the farmers didn't farm the packers
didn't pack and truckers didn't truck
guess what we would have starved to
death in new york
all of these americans work and they
actually
they were all hands on deck to help
their fellow americans including all the
medical professionals
that didn't stay in their basement
bunkers and hide
so congress i guess is above the the
farmers the packers
the medical manufacturers well this is
just
chuck schumer uh playing disaster
liberalism to its to its nth degree
this is uh how democrats and socialists
think they just think that
they never want to let a crisis go to
waste they want to use it for their pure
political
uh advantage even though we're a couple
hours since
uh senator tillis said that he tested
positive
uh senator mike lee tested positive by
the way these are the same democrats
who argued they don't even need to meet
with amy coney barrett they they don't
even think it's legitimate they don't
even want to meet with her
and now they suddenly want to delay
things they're going to throw
anything and everything at the wall
trying to confuse people
it's how they operate it's sickening
it's disgusting
it doesn't work people see right through
it but this is how chuck schumer
thinks i mean he's just not oozing with
you know
credibility on this issue what about all
things are on the table
ari uh core packings on the table ending
the legislative filibusters on the table
uh we're going to make d.c and puerto
rico
states without any input from the other
50 states and
and have a senate majority of democrats
in perpetuity
and joe won't answer that question
either does he get away with you know
going through the rest of this campaign
ignoring those important issues
well i think he's going to be under some
level of pressure but as we all know
most people in the mainstream media
really don't hold them accountable they
don't hold his feet to the fire and do
endless follow-ups and point out how
he's dodging him refused to go on and
just pound him on it they don't they
give him a pass
but sean it's not that these issues are
on the table they're about to be shoved
down our throat
they're about to leave the table and the
reason i say that is when you listen to
senator schumer who wants to be the
majority leader talk about how he didn't
wait to become the majority leader this
long to do nothing
he's implying he's going to abolish the
filibuster and if they pass
packing the courts do you think joe
biden's going to veto it
so i have no doubt in my mind if the
democrats win and if they take back the
senate
they're going to pack the court they're
going to abolish the filibuster
one of the first things they'll do is
create new states d.c will come to state
puerto rico will become a state they'll
pack the supreme court
and pack the united states senate it's a
power move
and how would that be jason chaffetz we
have about 30 seconds
i think this country will become become
unrecognizable people need to show up
they need to vote
they got they have no excuses they need
to talk to their friends they got to do
everything they can don't let anybody in
the media scare you intimidate you
try to cancel you get out there and vote
because these changes that are he's
talking about
they're very very real what they're
really talking about
i mean the fact that joe won't answer
i'm not falling for trump's trick
it's not a trick question do you want to
pack the court or not tell us
ahead of time joe pretty fundamental
anyway thank you both ari fleischer
former congressman chaffetz
our